just my dude to focus was it came to  happy to protect to my family  [Music]  I will Brianna jostle citizens we are  under attack from northern invaders  every family must contribute one none to  fight I am blessed with two daughters I  will fight  you must be strong this time he will not  return it is my duty to protect my  family  ancestors please protect her  what is your name soldier partying  committed son of haja  when they find out who you are they will  show you no mercy  [Music]  I'm home alone I will bring honor to us  all  [Music]  your majesty all tray has been disrupted  in a coordinated attack every family  will supply one man my father cannot  fight I will take his place  when they find out who you are they were  so you know mercy  [Music]  and Pamela well Briana to us off  you